[MUSIC PLAYING]
LIZ FONG-JONES:
Welcome to episode 9
of our series on SRE and DevOps.
I'm Liz Fong-Jones, a site
reliability engineer at Google,
where I teach Google Cloud
customers how to build
and operate reliable services.
SETH: And I'm Seth,
a developer advocate
at Google focused on
infrastructure and operations.
LIZ FONG-JONES: So
Seth, I was hoping
you would help me
figure out why are
things so chaotic every time
one of my services break?
SETH: So what kind of
chaos are you experiencing?
Too much data?
Slow internet connections?
Corporate firewalls?
VPNs?
LIZ FONG-JONES: No, that's
not actually what I mean.
I'm talking about human chaos.
There's often both too much
communication and too little
communication at the same time.
Everyone wants to participate.
People are doing random things
that don't actually help.
And people actually doing
the work aren't talking.
SETH: Ah, yes.
Humans are definitely an
important part of the incident
management process.
It sounds like you need
to define very clear roles
and responsibilities
for each of your humans,
so that they know
exactly what they can
do without getting in the way.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I'd
love to figure that out.
How do I get started, Seth?
SETH: First, you'll
need a process
for declaring
incidents, a dashboard
for viewing your
current incidents,
and some kind of
database for who
to contact when an
incident is in progress
for different
kinds of incidents.
You'll also need
to set thresholds
for when to declare
an incident and who
can declare an incident
in your organization.
Depending on the
scale of the incident,
you may also need to
bring in specialists
from other parts of
the company in order
to help resolve the incident.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Right.
I wouldn't necessarily
want to declare an incident
every single time and
get paged, but I also
wanted to feel supported in
declaring an incident if I
need to bring in other people.
Then what?
SETH: So I mentioned
having someone to contact.
The most critical role in
the incident response process
is that of incident
commander, or IC,
who is responsible for
making strategic decisions
and delegating additional
roles to other responders.
The other roles can also
be played by the incident
commander but tend to be
delegated as the incident grows
in size or complexity.
The first role that
tends to be created
is that of the
operations lead, who
is in charge of gaining a
detailed understanding of
and actually changing
the state of the system--
like running commands,
grabbing log files, et cetera.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I
gather that only knowing
having one person touching the
system makes a lot of sense,
but I'm not sure how that's
helpful to have the incident
commander isolated
from the details.
Don't they need to
know all those details?
SETH: So yes and no.
I mean, have you ever been
driving a car in the dark
in some foreign country on
the opposite side of the road,
and you're trying to get where
you need to go, but you can't?
LIZ FONG-JONES:
A few times, yes.
And it's super
difficult. I usually
have to pull over because
if there's no one else
in the car with me, I
can't both look at the map
and figure out where am I
going, where am I trying to go.
And then, I drive
safely at the same time.
I can't do that all at once.
SETH: Right.
So I think you just answered
your own question, right?
If we apply that same analogy
to the operations world,
it's hard to both
plan and perform
to keep track of all of
the fine-grained details
at the same time.
So it's usually best
to separate the two
roles to minimize the
overhead of context switching.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I see.
That makes a lot of sense.
So the incident commander and
the operations lead under them,
but you mentioned
multiple roles.
What other roles might
an incident commander
want to delegate?
SETH: Well, have you ever
had external stakeholders,
like a support team or
executives, who are bugging you
for updates during an outage?
LIZ FONG-JONES: All the time.
SETH: Or maybe if you're a
public-facing company, perhaps
you have a presence
on social media
where your users are
constantly nagging you
about the service being down.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Ah, it's
super distracting, especially
if I'm the operations lead.
But isn't that just the
incident commander's job to do?
SETH: Sometimes--
up to the point
that the incident commander
can no longer effectively
do both the planning and
the communications work.
At that point, you'll
want a communications lead
for communicating with other
teams or external stakeholders.
LIZ FONG-JONES: I see.
And what if an
incident grows so large
that the decision
making responsibility,
and the planning, and the
logistical work becomes
too much work for
one person to handle?
Then what?
SETH: So in that
scenario, you might
want to have a dedicated
planning lead--
having someone be in
charge of writing the plan,
maintaining the
running notes document,
and starting to draft
the post-mortem.
Another common role
is a logistics lead,
who handles things
like securing rooms,
making sure that people
have food and water,
and other supplies.
Or you could get more
creative, depending
on the needs of your
organization and your business.
LIZ FONG-JONES: That
makes a lot of sense.
What can't the incident
commander delegate, though?
It sounds like the
incident commander
can delegate anything.
SETH: So the incident
commander can't
delegate overall
decision-making responsibility.
The buck stops with them.
They have to help their
subordinates make decisions,
tiebreak in the event
that people can't agree,
and coordinate adding new people
into the incident response
hierarchy as deemed appropriate.
LIZ FONG-JONES:
And what if there
needs to be multiple people
working hands on keyboard,
or multiple people need to
be doing the communications?
How does that work?
I thought you said
only one person's
in charge of operations.
SETH: So additional
subject matter experts
can join under the
operations lead.
Or the overall
communications lead
might want to designate someone
to be on the customer support
team, while another person
is handling social media
for external communications.
LIZ FONG-JONES: And what
about the role of managers
and technical leads?
Do I automatically become
the incident commander
just because I'm the most
senior person who turned up?
SETH: No, not unless you're
specifically asked to.
The person who
declared the incident
is always the incident
commander until they
designate a successor.
It's up to them to decide
what roles in which
to place people joining
or even turn people away
if there are too many
cooks in the kitchen.
For long running incidents,
the incident commander
made delegate a successor in
a more appropriate time zone
or geography.
As an incident evolves
in size or complexity,
some incident commanders may
want to give up the role of IC
and instead become
the operations lead.
LIZ FONG-JONES: Great.
That should help clear
up some of the confusion
and chaos for my next incident.
Thanks, everyone, for watching.
And we hope you'll
tune in next time
to learn what to do
after an incident.
To find out when we post
our upcoming episodes,
please like and subscribe below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]